-First, we're about to
face off in a game of Drinko.
Drinko, do you want to explain
how the game works?
-Yes. Welcome to Drinko.
In this game, the two of you
will take turns
climbing my stairs
and dropping two of your disks
down the Drinko board.
The disks will plink down
and land in these plastic cups
containing some of my favorite
beverages such as...
Girl Scout Thin Mints,
cream-cheese water,
and garlic shot.
Your opponent
must drink the cocktail
of the two chosen drinks.
-Alright. Thank you very much.
-Cheese water?
-Drinko, what did you say again?
Did you say --
-Cream-cheese water!
-Alright.
-♪ It's water
with cream cheese! ♪
-That's my favorite --
That's a great
Harry styles song.
♪ Cream-cheese water, ah,
cream-cheese water ♪
Alright, Miles,
why don't you go up there first
because you're our guest?
-Sure.
-Climb up the steps of Drinko
and enjoy yourself
a good beverage.
-Yes. Thank you.
-Yeah, no problem.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Drinko, you okay?
-Drop the disk whenever
you're ready, Miles.
-Alright.
-Here it comes.
Cream-cheese water!
-Alright. Your first cup
will be the garlic shot.
-Garlic shot!
-[ Sad tuba plays ]
-It's a garlic shot.
-That's healthy.
-That's healthy for you.
That's not that bad.
And then you're gonna mix that
with another beverage
once you drop the second chip.
-Drop your second disks.
Here it comes.
Coming down the stairway.
Ginger kombucha.
-Ooh. Not bad actually.
-Ginger kombucha.
-Oh, my -- I'm -- This is great.
-Miles, you have
ginger kombucha...
Thank you, Drinko.
-I think they sell these --
-You wanna take those?
-You can buy this shot in a
store right now for like $14.
-Yeah, that's actually not bad.
You've got ginger kombucha
and garlic shot.
Not bad.
-Ooh.
-Place it in this nice cup
right there and enjoy yourself.
A garlic shot.
[ Audience groans ]
-Mmm!
-Alright.
♪♪
Good luck. Good to see you.
-Oh!
-Oh, that'll help.
That'll help.
-God, it's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Ahh. I feel lighter.
I don't know. I feel --
I'm so much healthier
than you right now.
-Your Adam's apple was shaking
as you were drinking.
[ Gurgling ]
-Yeah.
-Now it is your turn, James.
-What do you want me to do,
Drinko?
-I want you
to ascend the staircase
and drop two disks in me.
-Okay.
-Drinko's getting
a little bossy.
-Drinko.
-I'm sorry. On me. All over me.
-Alright, all right.
-Climb the -- Unh! Eh! Ah!
Unh! Eee! Ooh! Ooh! Ohh...
Drop the disk, baby.
♪♪
-Alright. I want to stay away
from cream-cheese water.
-No.
-I'm going to throw up
if I do cream-cheese water.
Is that good right here?
-Here we go.
-No! Stay away from that side!
Yes! Good, good, good.
Oh, no, oh, no!
-No! Yoo-hoo!
-Yoo-hoo! Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Drop the second disk.
-Ugh. Let's just do it.
Alright. Here we go.
-Come on, cream-cheese water!
[ Drinko grunting ]
-No, no, no. Please.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, James.
You must drink
my cream-cheese water.
-I hate this game. I --
I just -- It's not.
-That's the cream --
-It is not!
♪♪
Why in the world?!
-♪ Cream-cheese water ♪
Two drinks, one cup.
[ Audience groans ]
There you go.
♪♪
-Ugh!
-Cream-cheese water.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, it might pair well
with Yoo-hoo.
-You can do it, James.
You can do it.
Oh, that's the Yoo-hoo.
♪♪
-[ Groans ] I really --
This type of stuff. I can't --
I can't do it. I can't.
Like --
-You can do it. You can do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Coughs ]
♪♪
[ Coughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow!
Ohh!
-How's that?
-Not so bad.
-It's so gross.
-Yeah.
-It's so --
What's the worst part is,
it's still in the beard.
[ Laughter ]
It is so gross.
Gosh, that is disgusting.
Okay.
-Cream-cheese water.
Are you ready
for the final round?
-Yeah. Okay.
This is gonna be a race.
We're both gonna climb up
there. It's not over now?
-No, one more round.
-What's the final round?
-Both of you climb up
and drop a disk.
Whosever first disk lands first
is the winner,
and the loser has to drink
the cocktail of both beverages.
♪ Let's go ♪
♪♪
-Oh. Wait. What is it?
-Both of you
climb up the stairs.
-Alright.
-Both of you drop a disk.
-We're dropping two disks?
-Yes, at the same time.
Whoever's disk gets there
first wins.
The other person has to drink
the drink, the loser's drink.
-I think the Drinko guy
is drunk. I don't think --
-Oh, yeah.
-That's why they call me Drinko.
[ Laughter ]
-Drinko, wait.
Where do we find you, Drinko?
-Ready?
I'm going to count to three.
-Drinko, where did we find you?
-You didn't find me.
I found you.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
So we're both dropping --
We're both dropping
at the same time.
-At the same time. I will
count down, "3, 2, 1, drop."
Are you ready?
-Yes.
Where are you putting yours?
On the line?
-Right here.
-Okay.
-3, 2, 1, drop.
♪♪
-Oh, I'm toast.
-Yo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What'd you get?
What did we get?
Is it more cream-cheese water!
This is the best game ever!
Drinko, Drinko, Drinko!
What did we get?
Yoo-hoo...
-Well, I think I've got the...
-And the garlic shot again?
Dude.
-Oh, garlic shot.
-What do you -- What do you --
I'll give you -- You can add
one more thing to mine.
-Okay.
-Bone broth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Audience
shouting suggestions ]
-Mustard juice.
♪♪
Cream-cheese water.
-No.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They -- The audience
turned on me so fast.
It's like...
-They loved you
when you come out.
-I come out. They're like,
"Oh, 'Top Gun," this and that."
For this, they're like...
-"Cream-cheese water."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You guys are mean.
-Good luck. Are you -- Do you
have a good, strong stomach?
-No. I do have, like, a fairly
sensitive gag reflex.
-I can't think about what I did.
The Yoo-hoo helped me.
That's not Yoo-hoo.
That's garlic.
And that's the Yoo-hoo.
-Here comes the Yoo-hoo.
-I'm gonna add a little
cranberry into this one.
-Oh, my God.
-Take it to the "finish."
-That's a lot to chug.
-Turn and burn, baby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God! Legend!
♪♪
Legend right there!
-i haven't seen you
since "Top Gun: Maverick"
was the number-one --
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-The number-one movie that --
I think it's --
I think it's the fifth highest
grossing film
in American history.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations, buddy.
-Yeah, still climbing.
-You did it.
-Every day.
-Yeah, every -- that is correct.
-Yeah.
-Uh, it's bigger than
we even thought
it was gonna be.
-Oh, for sure.
-It was fantastic.
-I know, people just --
people really love --
Well, they love Tom Cruise,
which -- as they should.
He's dedicated...
-Of course.
-...so much of his life
to entertaining audiences.
But people just love "Top Gun."
-Yeah.
-They cannot get enough of it.
-I love the story, though.
I love you.
You did it so -- you were --
it was just --
Everything was great.
-Thank you.
-Jennifer Connelley.
-I know, right?
She's so good.
-The greatest in everything.
But we had --
-Val, a nice --
a really touching performance
from Val.
-I lost it.
I even knew that was
gonna happen, and I --
I watched it, and I was like --
I still lost it.
-How did you know
it was gonna happen?
-I have an inside scoop.
-A little inside --
-Yeah, yeah.
-Well, you're in the biz, Jimmy.
-Well, you know, I had Jon --
Jon Hamm was on the show
a couple times.
And he told me that, you know,
you met the royals...
-Yes.
-...because you screened it
in London.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And it was like -- and it --
and he was telling me, he goes,
"Yeah, it was really
interesting and fun."
And he said that the cast
was all told,
"Hey, be very polite.
Don't say too much."
-Oh, they give -- they give you,
like, a full kind of rules,
like do's and don'ts.
And there's, you know, a lot of
etiquette, which deservingly so.
So, yeah, I was actually --
I kind of had a sheet to prep
to make sure
I didn't mess it up.
-But then he said --
-Yeah.
-Well, I have just a photo.
And I just want you
to explain the photo,
'cause here's you talking.
-Yeah.
-There's Jennifer Connelley.
-Right.
-Little concerned.
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Laughing.
-Sure.
-Right?
Kate Middleton laughing.
And then --
-Yeah.
-He's going, "Mm-hmm."
-"Mm-hmm."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-And so what is happening?
Can you tell us the story of
what's going on with this?
-I think right off the bat,
I messed up.
You're not supposed to, like,
extend your hand
right off the bat unless --
unless they do.
But I felt the vibe,
so I was like, "I'm --"
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "I'm going in.
I'm going in."
-"Felt the vibe."
-And to their credit,
they were very disarming,
and this and that.
But, yeah, if you --
I think right there,
I'm honestly lost
in Prince William's -- in his --
in his eyes.
[ Laughter ]
-Tell me about this, though.
-His eyes?
-No. But yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, blue
as the bluest ocean, Jimmy.
What do you want?
-You get right in there,
and you go, "Hi,"
and you just start going gaga?
-Kind of.
Like, um, and Kate is very --
You know, she's...
-Yeah.
-...beautiful and very,
you know, cordial and...
-Stunning, yeah.
-...holds herself so well.
-Regal.
-Yeah, regal.
And with William, I don't know.
I just --
[ Laughter ]
I blacked out.
-I just think -- this photo,
I just think --
And then Jennifer Connelley
looks at you, she goes,
"That was weird
what you just did to him."
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause she knew, 'cause I was
standing next to Jen.
So I was kind of --
I don't know.
I was kind of riffing on what --
what this interaction
was gonna be like.
So I think she was already
on alert about --
if she thought I was gonna
go a bit rogue
about the whole thing.
But I think he's
a lifelong fan now.
-Yeah, now --
now he has to be, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He felt the vibe was the best.
You know --
-Just picking up
what he was putting down.
-I want to give a shout-out
to your grandma, by the way,
if she's watching.
-Oh, for sure.
-Hi, grandma.
-Yeah.
-You're so proud of your
grandson here.
She's on Twitter, and she said,
"They're looking for an actor
to replace Daniel Craig
for a 007.
I think my grandson,
Miles Teller,
has proven that he has
everything they're looking for.
Talent, looks, strength,
worldwide appeal,
and, oh, so cool."
[ Laughter ]
"He can be that guy!!
Wouldn't he be great?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yeah.
-You had no idea
she was going to do this?
-No.
And I'm not -- look.
I set her up
her Twitter many years ago.
-Yeah.
-I'm not gonna tell her
what to do with it.
-No.
-Do what you want, grandma,
you know?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-If you want to --
if you want to --
-But I am actually here
to make an announcement.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Still not 007.
-All right, well, hey.
You know -- it's so --
-Nobody's -- nobody's called.
-No one's called yet.
-Yeah, yeah.
-We got to get Barbara Broccoli
on the phone here
and make this official.
I mean, I could see you as 007.
-Yeah, why not?
-I mean --
-Yeah, you know?
What do you guys think?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Why not?
-Mix it up.
Why not do it?
-But I am available.
[ Laughter ]
-This is one of my favorite
times of the year,
because this is
"Saturday Night Live"
season premiere time...
-Oh, my God.
-...and I'm so --
As a comedian, even before
I was on "Saturday Night Live,"
I get excited in September.
I go, "Oh, this is
'Saturday Night Live.'"
There's some new cast members.
-I know.
-And it's just fun.
We want it, we need it.
-Definitely new cast members
this year, yeah.
-Yeah. Oh, yeah.
This is fantastic.
-I know, I know.
-Are you nervous?
Are you excited?
-I'm very --
Yeah, I mean,
it's all those things.
Like I --
in my family, growing up,
"SNL" was, you know,
an institution.
It still is.
-Yeah.
-You know, the years that you
were there and before that --
you know, Cheri Oteri and
Will Farrell and Chris Kattan
and Ana Gasteyer
and Molly Shannon,
like, those were --
-Love it.
-It was a real thing.
And, you know, my sisters and I
would do the skits,
and our close family friends,
it was our collective dream
to one day, you know,
either be a cast member on "SNL"
or to host,
so, it's very --
-Did you get any advice
from any other --
-That's why I'm here.
Give me some advice.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Like, what do you --
-Uh, yeah.
Try everything.
-Yeah.
-Try and believe in the writers.
-Sounds like college.
-Believe -- yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
Believe in the writers.
Believe in the producers.
They're all
the best of the best.
And they'll all just --
and you do it.
Whatever works is gonna work.
Just try everything
and just go all out.
It's just -- honestly.
And they all love you already.
I already heard word back
from down the hall.
-Okay, good.
-Yeah, and they said,
"Yeah, he's a good guy."
-Okay, good.
-"We love Miles Teller."
-Good, good.
-Yeah.
-Guys, I'm freaking out.
-No, yeah.
It's good.
-No, I'm excited.
-You should.
You should freak out
the whole time.
-You know, you're --
I get -- I just --
I'm excited to see
how it all works.
-It's live TV, man.
-You know what I mean?
-It's fun. No one does live TV
anymore, so it's great.
-Yeah.
-So congratulations.
Break a leg.
You're gonna be great.
-Thank you.
-And you got
Kendrick Lamar, too.
-Oh, my God.
-So everyone's watching
this Saturday.
It's gonna be fun.